>>> TODAY A GLIT IN VLADIMIR
PUTIN'S PROPAGANDA MACHINE.
THE RUSSIAN PRESIDENT WAS
ADDRESSING THE NATION,
CELEBRATING HIS 2014 ANNEXATION
OF CRIMEA.
BUT HIS BIG SPEECH CUT OFF
BEFORE HE WAS FINISHED.
YOU'LL SEE IT RIGHT HERE.
THE SHOT CUTTING TO A GROUP OF
SINGERS.
THE KREMLIN SAYS IT WAS A
TECHNICAL GLITCH AND THE SPEECH
WAS LATER REPLAYED IN ITS
ENTIRETY.
THE KREMLIN IS ALSO REACTING
ANGRILY TO TOUGH AND PERSONAL
WORDS FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN ABOUT
PUTIN.
THE NUMBER TWO OFFICIAL AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT TODAY PROMISING
A THOROUGH EFFORT TO DOCUMENT
POSSIBLE RUSSIAN WAR CRIMES, BUT
SAID PUTIN'S HOLD ON POWER WAS
NOT A FACTOR IN ADMINISTRATION
POLICY.
>> THE UNITED STATES SUPPORT
REGIME CHANGE IN RUSSIA?
>> THAT IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
ABOUT.
WE ARE NOT -- THIS IS A DECISION
FOR THE PEOPLE OF RUSSIA.
>> WITH ME TO SHARE THEIR
REPORTING AND INSIGHTS, DAVID
SANGER OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
VIVIAN OF "THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL."
DAVID, LET'S START WITH YOU.
YOU WROTE A FASCINATING PIECE
TODAY ABOUT HOW THIS IS
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S INSTINCT.
HE MAKES BIG THINGS PERSONAL.
SO LET'S LISTEN.
WENDY SHERMAN THERE SAYING WE'RE
NOT ABOUT REGIME CHANGE.
BUT SHE ALSO KNOWS THAT POKES
PUTIN.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IN RECENT DAYS POKING
PUTIN.
>> VERY PUBLIC STANDING TOGETHER
AGAINST A MURDEROUS DICTATOR.
A PURE THUG WHO IS WAGING AN
IMMORAL WAR AGAINST THE PEOPLE
OF UKRAINE.
>> ARE YOU READY TO CALL HIM A
WAR CRIMINAL?
>> HE IS A WAR CRIMINAL.
>> PROS AND CONS?
>> THE PRO HERE IS THE PRESIDENT
SAYING WHAT SEEMS EVIDENT TO US
WATCHING THE VIDEO THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN PLAYING THROUGHOUT THE
WHOLE SHOW, JOHN.
YOU TAKE A LOOK AT CIVILIANS
BEING TARGETED.
THAT'S THE DEFINITION OF WAR
CRIMES.
AND THE MORE HE SAYS THIS, THE
MORE THE MESSAGE IS GOING TO
MAKE ITS WAY OUT, INCLUDING TO
THE RUSSIAN PEOPLE.
THEY HAVE TO SAY THAT THIS IS
NOT ABOUT REGIME CHANGE AND IN
THE SHORT RUN IT'S PROBABLY NOT,
BUT IN THE LONG RUN, OF COURSE,
THE PREVIOUS TIMES WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT LEADERS LIKE THIS ARE
SADDAM HUSSEIN, RIGHT, BASHAR
ASSAD WHO IS STILL IN POWER BUT
WE ACCUSED OF WAR CRIMES AND
SAID WE COULDN'T IMAGINE SYRIA
GOING ON WITH HIM AS THE LEADER.
WELL, HE'S STILL A LEADER.
THE DOWN SIDE THAT A CORNERED
PUTIN, IF HE IS FAILING ON THE
BATTLEFIELD AND BELIEVES,
WHETHER IT'S TRUE OR NOT, THAT
THE UNITED STATES IS TRYING TO
STOKE OPPOSITION TO HIM AT HOME,
IS MUCH MORE LIKELY TO REACH FOR
EXTREME MEASURES.
AND RIGHT NOW WE'RE HEARING FROM
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY QUITE
PUBLICLY THAT THOSE EXTREME
MEASURES ARE CHEMICAL AND
BIOLOGICAL, AND WE'RE HEARING
FROM THE DEFENSE INTELLIGENCE
AGENCY THAT THEY BELIEVE HE'LL
THREATEN THE USE OF NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
I DON'T THINK HE'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS,
UNLESS NATO IS ACTUALLY IN
UKRAINE.
BUT THOSE -- THAT'S THE DOWN
SIDE.
>> LET'S LISTEN TO THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ON THAT POINT ABOUT
POSSIBLE RUSSIAN USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
TO HEAR THIS PUBLICLY IS SO
STARTLING.
>> WE BELIEVE THAT MOSCOW MAY BE
SETTING THE STAGE TO USE A
CHEMICAL WEAPON AND THEN FALSELY
BLAME UKRAINE TO JUSTIFY
ESCALATING ITS ATTACKS ON THE
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE.
MANUFACTURING EVENTS AND
CREATING FALSE NARRATIVES OF
GENOCIDE TO JUSTIFY GREATER USE
OF MILITARY FORCE IS A TACTIC
THAT RUSSIA HAS USED BEFORE.
>> IT IS A TACTIC THEY'VE USED
BEFORE, BUT ONE OF THE
TRADEMARKS OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS HAS BEEN GETTING
WAY OUT AHEAD.
DISCLOSING INTELLIGENCE
PUBLICLY.
THE RUSSIANS ARE BUILDING UP
TROOPS.
THEY PLAN TO INVADE.
THEY'VE PROVED RIGHT.
THEY WERE PRIT IN THOSE
DECLARATIONS.
SO WHEN YOU HEAR THAT, IT GIVES
YOU EVEN MORE CHILLS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND, OBVIOUSLY, THIS HAS BEEN
PART OF THE RUSSIAN PLAYBOOK NOT
JUST IN THIS CONFLICT WHERE
WE'VE SEEN EVERYTHING PLAY OUT
AS THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
PREDICT BUD RUSSIA ALSO HAS A
PATTERN OF DOING THIS.
NOT JUST HELPING OTHER DICTATORS
AROUND THE WORLD USE CHEMICAL
WEAPONS BUT ALSO GOING AGAINST
THEIR OWN ADVERSARIES.
ADVERSARIES OF THE REGIME TO USE
CHEMICAL WEAPONS AGAINST THEM
OR, YOU KNOW, ANY KIND OF -- ANY
KIND OF CHEMICAL THAT WOULD
BASICALLY INFLICT SEVERE HARM.
AND SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
THE U.N. HAS EXPRESSED CONCERN
ABOUT.
THE ADMINISTRATION, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION EXPRESSING
CONCERN ABOUT.
AND THEY CONTINUE TO RAMP UP
PRESSURE.
I SPOKE TO AN OFFICIAL THIS WEEK
WHO WAS TELLING ME, A LARGE PART
OF THE INTELLIGENCE HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN DECLASSIFIED AND DOWNGRADED
SO THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE TO
RAMP UP PUBLIC PRESSURE AGAINST
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AND SO DEFINITELY WHEN WE DO
HEAR THE SECRETARY OF STATE OR
ANYONE IN THE ADMINISTRATION
GOING OUT THERE AND SAYING
ANYTHING, ESPECIALLY GIVEN HOW
SPOT ON THEIR TRACK RECORD HAS
BEEN WITH THE INTELLIGENCE AND
THIS CONFLICT, YOU HAVE TO SAY,
OKAY, THIS IS GETTING REALLY
BAD.
>> LET ME PICK EACH OF YOUR
REPORTING BEFORE WE GO.
WE'RE WAITING TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THIS CALL BETWEEN THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND CHINESE COUNTERPART.
WHAT IS THE SENSE THE WHITE
HOUSE AS -- GOAL ONE IS KEEP THE
CHINESE FROM DIRECTLY HELPING
RUSSIA.
THE QUESTION IS, IS THERE ANY
SCENARIO UNDER WHICH THE CHINESE
WOULD THEN TURN TO TRY TO DO
SOMETHING TO HELP THE UNITED
STATES?
VIVIAN?
>> THE CHINESE OBVIOUSLY DO WANT
TO WORK WITH THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WANT A TRADE RELATIONSHIP.
THEY WANT TO ENGAGE TO A CERTAIN
EXTENT, BUT AT THE SAME TIME
THEY ALSO LIKE PLAYING BOTH
SIDES.
AND FOR THEM TO HAVE VLADIMIR
PUTIN SORT OF COMING OUT THERE
WITH HIS HANDS OUT SAYING, CAN
YOU PLEASE HELP US, IT PUTS THEM
IN A VERY STRONG POSITION.
AND SO THEY BELIEVE THAT HAVING
THAT KIND OF DUAL HATTEDNESS,
WHERE ON THE OTHER HAND DON'T
SLAM THE DOOR IN RUSSIA'S FACE.
>> WE ALWAYS WANT TO KNOW THE
ANSWER TODAY.
THE CHINESE TEND TO TAKE A
LONGER VIEW.
>> THEY DO.
IF YOU WANT THE MODEL HERE, LOOK
HOW THEY DEALT WITH NORTH KOREA.
VARIOUS MOMENTS THEY'VE CRACKED
DOWN ON THEM ABOUT THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
AND THEN SLOWLY THEY'VE RESUMED
TRADE BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE THAT
STAYING ENGAGED WITH THEM GIVES
THEM SOME LEVEL OF CONTROL AND
INFLUENCE.
AND WHO HATES BE